the problem is going to come when we
reach a ceiling that we can't raise and
that is the lending ceiling that is the
willingness of the rest of the world to
loan US money the crazy part about it is
we tell our creditors if we can't borrow
more money we will default well we're
basically telling the creditors that
this is a Ponzi scheme the politicians
should be saying if we don't raise a
debt ceiling we are going to cut Social
Security we're going to cut Medicare and
we're going to prioritize interest on
the national debt or we're going to have
an emergency tax hike we're going to
raise everybody's taxes so we can pay
the debt no they don't say that they say
if we can't borrow more money we're
defaulting so how much longer can this
go on because default is inevitable it's
only a question of when the other thing
that they can do if they're not going to
default well they just print well then
there's hyperinflation and that's the
same thing it's actually worse than
defaulting